did you know that once a part of Kale's
questline actually had you looking
around for a bird with a letter struck
to its leg have you seen a crow around
here by any chance you know a burial
Crow with a letter fastened to its claw
I'd give you a generous sum for it of
course and down here we can find it a
so-called burial Crow and if you kill it
in time you can loot the burial Crow's
letter which progresses kali's questline
helping him to locate the underground
area where his brothers were entombed
long ago this event in particular is a
restoration of Kale's cut questline and
if you'd like to see the full thing then
sakuro dubi has a full restoration of it
over on their Channel but it's not just
the questline that might relate to the
burial crows you know those notes that
you usually buy from Merchants that give
you hints about the world well according
to some version 1.0 text it's also
possible that hunting burial crows was
originally the method by which you were
supposed to loot these notes and while
we're talking about the merchants did
you know that at one point there was
planned to be a traveling Merchant who
actually wandered around the map in Lim
grave according to secular dubi again
evidence that the merchants actually
traveled survives in the unused walk
routes that are found in a couple of
Elden Rings old maps for example this is
NPC 802 who could be found here on the
western coast before they set up here by
the bridge of sacrifice south of the
evergail then here in the Mistwood and
then finally at storm Hill near the
Saints Bridge to be clear NPC 802 is an
earlier type of merchant one that
actually had much deeper law at the time
as the story goes this Merchant is
actually aware of the dungeon underneath
Landell where his brothers are entombed
and now he wanders around out of fear
fear of staying in the same place and
being locked up like his kin it's great
storytelling and it's a shame it was cut
because I think Elden ring would have
really benefited from more Dynamic
events like this for number three so one
of the best strategies for taking out
the godskin duo is sleep it takes one
God skin out of commission entirely
allowing the fight to become more of a
one-on-one but you likely knew this
already what you might not have known is
that the god skin are actually supposed
to be able to wake each other up and
this isn't even cut content there's
actually just a bug that prevents this
interaction from taking place most of
the time as far as I can tell this was
first noted by Lil Aggie while they were
doing a randomized race through Elden
ring and then in a comment thread
started by zeostorm everyone got to work
uncovering the truth and according to
this Twitter user the godskin boss is
actually able to perform this scream in
The Windmill Village as long as you blew
them down the hill where a celebrant is
asleep so why doesn't it work in the
godskin arena well according to the
fifth mat on Twitter the godskin AI is
supposed to do this waking animation if
a friend is found to be asleep but the
Ally detection is kind of bugged out in
this Arena because of the knights that
Patrol outside so when the fifth match
removed every single night patrolling
around the arena as well as the hidden
HP bar enemy apparently it worked in
their Arena again this might explain why
the waking Behavior Works only in Boss
randomizers because a lot of these end
up with you fighting the godskin outside
of their Arena so there aren't any
patrolling enemies to bug out this
intended effect when you play on the
randomizer as for a law explanation well
sleep and death are kind of similar in
the real world in the sense that you're
unconscious and they do also seem to
over lap as Concepts in the Elden ring
world as well as I discussed in my
mikula lore video so it does make some
sense that the godskins being deeply
aware of death might have also developed
a way to wake each other out of it
though that is just speculation but
speaking of death did you know that some
of those who live in death can do this
I could try to explain this but I think
some things are just better without any
explanation you know
what also doesn't need any further
explanation at this point is just how
inspired from software are by cantato
miyota's berserk but just when you think
you've seen every berserk reference
possible another reading reveals another
reference I was reading chapter 82 and I
looked at this panel and it showed
Griffith's last tier that was frozen
crystallized making it look identical to
the crystal tears that once fell from
the earth tree
another consistent thing in a lot of
fromms games is the presence of an enemy
that should be hostile but isn't and in
Elden ring that phenomenon shows up here
towards the end of Langdale Capital past
a set of Miss forgotten there's a
friendly dog who won't attack you no
matter what you do hopefully they never
fix this in an update but one thing they
have finally fixed though is the raw
Medallion it used to be that this only
buffed a few raw effects but now it
properly Buffs a broad spectrum of
attacks including the raw based Dragon
communion incantations aspect of The
Crucible breath and even placidus axes
ruin couple this with the Highland ax
which also Buffs raw attacks and can
simply be put in your off hand and
you'll be a force to be reckoned with
there's good potential for a raw build
here somewhere now I think for number
eight another thing that pops up in
almost every from software game is the
presence of a character named Yulia in
Demon Souls it was urea the witch in
Dark Souls it was the undead Merchant
who muttered the name Yulia maybe
talking about his sword or perhaps the
female Undead Merchant we're still not
really sure who he was calling Yulia but
anyway then Yulia was actually a
character in Dark Souls 3 and then she
was a major character in day rasane and
then she was even a character in Eldon
ring 4 the name was changed that's right
if you go through the cut dialog you'll
find lines spoken from an earlier time
in development and back then there was a
man named horalu the gold mask and Lady
Yulia was the name of the deathbed
companion who became fear and speaking
of fear there's something extremely
curious going on here at the
northernmost minor Earth tree upon the
Altus Plateau here an omen can be found
hunched over in a circle with a set of
commoners around them but what's really
weird about these enemies is that these
are all unique character models The Omen
has a black cape and the commoners have
a black set with a shroud over their
face but it's not just the models they
actually have unique casting animations
as well the commoners and The Omen are
capable of casting fears missed complete
with the little smoky symbol of death
that fears specifically does conjure up
I guess you could speculate that these
enemies are sort of Agents of fear
considering that fears mist is a unique
death blight incantation that was
developed specifically by her but at the
very least even if that's not true
they're clearly aligned with Godwin's
death blight and maybe even the new age
that his ending portends to
it's also really curious that they're
positioned right underneath what is a
unique minor herb tree this one is
almost entirely dead which reminds me
then of the shadow of the urge teaser
which might be showing Godwin's death
route clawing its way up around a dead
or dying Earth tree so I wonder if this
little group is related to that
anyway speaking of the shadow of the old
tree teaser there's a few more things
believe it or not in that image that I
wish I pointed out in my speculation
video first is the wheat I mentioned
that wheat is a symbol of abundance and
plenty and I theorized that that might
be related to Nicola since he's all
about abundance as a character but this
was then further validated by quayler
who went into the hay League trees
prayer room and actually found what
looks like wheat sticking out of a pot
here amazing find honestly a few of you
guys in the comments also pointed out
that a field of reads is imagery that's
associated with the Egyptian afterlife
which is considered to be the transition
to the next stage of one's Eternal
journey in my speculation video I talked
about how mikola might be experiencing
some sort of afterlife in this image so
I love how the Egyptian an afterlife
imagery really aligns with that and
lastly I didn't mention the round graves
because I didn't really have much to say
about them but a few of you guys also
pointed out that these might represent
the shape of mikola's great Rune we
don't know what his Rune looks like of
course but great runes typically are a
circle with a line through them so the
idea that Nicholas might look like this
is a very compelling Theory as well so
shout out to everyone involved in
bringing these theories to light turns
out my 15-minute speculation video on
one image wasn't long enough apparently
and speaking of giant dead trees and
things that I never mentioned I also
never got to point out this detail about
Crucible Knight soluria who stands
within a giant tree at the deep root
depths sometimes very rarely we can
learn something not just from weapons or
their description but from the name of
their weapon arts and the weapon art of
soluria's tree is soloria's woe which
suggests that she's despairing about
something it could be that she's just
lost and dejected in the same way that
so many Crucible Knights are scattered
around the lands between you know
without a lord to lead them or maybe
considering that she can be specifically
found and fought within a giant dead
tree maybe she's despairing about the
age of The Crucible that has long since
passed and the bygone primordial Earth
tree that her weapon is modeled after
it's food for thought
in the last Secrets video I talked to
length about Bell bearings and I also
talked about the ball bells that their
name was likely inspired by we trade
these Bell bearings to the twin Maiden
husks and since then I've been made
aware that this staff that they're
holding is actually called a kagura suzu
which were often used in traditional
Japanese dancers and they consist of 12
Bell bowls called suzu which supposedly
allow one to acquire positive power and
authority while repelling evil next
comes via a tweet from Zio storm who
actually does a lot of those Secrets
videos as well if you're interested in
watching some more he he reminds us all
of the grand Spirit tree Shield which is
a shield in Dark Souls 2 that depicts
the blue Spirit tree that I quote is
said to possess Divine powers and it
appears in the allegory of Keller the
god of dream it goes on to say that once
there was a boy who was easily
frightened until the talking tree of the
dream world transformed itself into a
shield to protect him obviously the name
Keller is just so similar to the name
mikola and mikola is considered a young
boy as well and as we discussed in our
Michela lore video mikla is heavily tied
to dreams and a dream world via their
alter ego who is Saint Trina and in the
teaser we see them with a giant tree so
there's a lot to unpack here but I
personally don't think there's much more
here than just from software continuing
a naming convention that they started
with dark souls 2. I feel like Nikola is
just the spiritual successor of a theme
that they started in Dark Souls 2. I
don't think that Dark Souls 2 is
actually related to Elden ring
canonically or anything like that it's
more that I think that from software
have these Concepts and themes and
naming conventions that they keep
persisting in developing throughout all
their games
but on that note I feel like we should
definitely keep an eye out in the future
for all of the other gods that are
listed on Dark Souls 2's name engraved
ring because Keller is one of them and
who knows what other names might show up
but speaking of Dark Souls I'd love to
shout out the fact that this plate have
just launched a new storefront filled
with these officially licensed designs
and for a limited time only you can get
20 off if you order one or two displays
and 30 off if you order more than three
with a link in the description the
designs here are really good but what
really sets this plate apart are the
metal plates and the printing process
that they use I'm still waiting for the
official Dark Souls designs to get
shipped out so let me show off some of
my own designs here so you can see what
I mean so even though they're printed on
metal displayed honestly match or even
exceed the quality of many paper printed
samples that I've tried over the years
the colors are rich the blacks are deep
and they do this all while being more
durable and more scratch resistant and
waterproof as well they're also easier
to hang with sticky pads that won't
damage your walls so if you want to show
off your love of dark souls in a unique
and long lasting way then please buy
with the link in the description
thanks to display for sponsoring this
video and let's get back to it so for
number 14 throughout this whole video
I've referenced that mikola lore video
that I made and I referenced it a lot
but one thing that I did get wrong in
that video was regarding the albanorics
back then I said that the albinorex
never once entered the presence of the
helic tree I thought this because of the
ivory sickle description which states
that these weapons are evidence of the
albinorex dedication to the helic tree
despite never having entered its
presence the ivory sickle says that and
I took this to mean that no albanorics
had ever made it to the helic tree but
that's actually not true it's probably
just talking about the albionics that
wheeled this weapon because as pointed
out by a commenter named Van ja and a
few others in the comments there are
actually many albanorics here they're
just all inside of cocoons you can see
their bodies here if you look really
closely and Benja speculates that they
seem to have died during a process of
metamorphosis mimicking mikola himself
when he sealed himself in a cocoon and
into the helic tree so I really like
this Theory I like that there's a
parallel between these characters it
would make sense that these creatures
and many others in the helic tree might
hope for a sort of rebirth and it's
pretty fascinating to learn that this
rebirth might have been in the process
of taking place just by the
environmental storytelling which is
amazing so thank you for pointing out
that environmental detail that I missed
another thing that I wish I brought up
in the video is that in version 1.0 of
Eldon ring carrier was at one stage
actually documented as having a good
relationship with mikola what I'm about
to read is version 1.0's description of
the royal guard set which eventually
became Loretta's Royal Knight set it
reads silver armor of the Abba Sentinels
who serve the sacred tree of mikola the
Scion imperian hailing from Raya lucaria
these Enchanted Knights once belonged to
the icarian royal family but were later
gifted to mikola recipient of The Vision
by King consort Radigan the lapis blue
timings reveal these Origins so Radigan
gifted the Sentinels to mikola Radigan
was involved in this gifting so I
speculate that he and ranala were still
married at this time which would explain
why he's making decisions on behalf of
karia here also clearly the concept of
Arbor Sentinels was scrapped and
replaced with Loretta who does serve a
somewhat similar role though she is said
to have left carrier of her own free
will this description also calls mikola
the recipient of the vision which I
think is likely referencing a line of
dialogue from Enya who calls America the
Visions vessel so since mikola is an
empyrean and worthy of becoming a God
Like America was it's likely that he was
a recipient of the vision in the same
sense as Marika interesting that the
greater will has a vision for the lands
between
but maybe that should be the topic of
another video again this is an item
description that's available on version
1.0 the velden ring and version 1.0 is
technically playable by the majority of
people as it's just the version of the
game that is on the physical console
disc if you never update it so unlike
some other cut content it is closer to
the final version of the game and thus
perhaps also the developer's final
vision for the game and the lore as well
but that's it for this video thank you
for watching and I'll see you next time